so what about a perfect day in the life
of Vaccaro when you're not doing a
perfect day a perfect day would be
something along the lines of I get up
very early like three four o'clock in
the morning drive an hour away and go
climb mountains that's the perfect day
out in the mountains oh oh do you mean a
normal non yeah a perfectly productive
normal day oh perfectly productive okay
so perfectly productive would be along
the lines that I wake up at like 7 30 8
o'clock probably I watch either
Bloomberg or CNBC for 30 minutes to an
hour
um and then watch the markets for maybe
maybe an hour or two look at certain
things that are you really care about
investing uh I do follow it quite
closely yeah I follow the markets very
closely closer than I should but yes for
personal reasons so do do you comment on
it like do you like for personal
investing reasons or for like
philosophical understanding what's going
on in the world it's it's sort of
everything I think first of all
obviously I'm interested in investing I
have been for many many years I've done
investing trading for at least a decade
now
um so like I am very interested on that
level I'm also quite interested as well
because when you see the policy that's
being dictated like you look in the last
last six months specifically you see the
FED policy around things like interest
rates unemployment things of this nature
it is something that interests me also
because I do invest in real estate aside
from the stock market so therefore I'm
always keeping an eye on these sorts of
things and and always looking and as a
better example like I'm looking for
Trends so if we go back to I think it
was 20 I could have the year wrong it
was 2015 or 2016.
um there was a pattern that I found that
on the FED minutes that came out uh you
know I believe 2 215 I think it's on the
Wednesday of every third Wednesday of
every month
um that gold would actually the gold
ETFs and etns would actually go up uh
not every single every single Wednesday
of the month that the minutes came out
so I would follow things like that now
of course I wasn't like trading huge
huge volume but I found a trend there of
course it stopped working at a certain
point but those are the sorts of things
that they just interest me even if it's
not something I'm doing to make a living
trying to spot those Trends it's always
been something that has uh that has
fascinated me
one Reddit said that you shorted Tesla
some time ago uh do you regret doing so
uh well when I when I did those plays I
was only those small amounts of money
and that was only via uh via puts that
was where I would buy puts or put
spreads um on it so it wasn't something
where I was straight shorting I would I
would never actually do that
um because it's just it's not worth the
risk and I don't want to ever be in a
situation where I have to think about
those sorts of things and I think a
better example is there was a period in
2016 actually shortly before the
candidates when I actually was in oil I
had a long position in oil and this is
when oil completely crashed it went very
I don't think it went below did it go
below 30 even it went very low and and
of course the Saudis were not cutting
they were not um I think they they were
uh were they cutting or not cutting
production but anyway there was a period
in 2016 when I had a big long position
in one of the 3x oil ETFs and I I it
kept going down day after day after day
and then of course right near the bottom
of my finally couldn't take it anymore I
took a loss and that really sort of it
was very difficult dealing with that the
stress every day looking seeing those
losses and after that I kind of decided
I would never put myself in such a
situation again
um and so that's why like I don't I
don't do shorting and then separately
and I think I post a reply to this
comment but in 2021 as Tesla started
going up I actually started selling puts
and I did quite well off of that so it's
it's sort of play Both Sides never never
like become hard set with your
conviction like where you refuse like
this is this is just like it has to go
down or like it it has to go up just
sure you'd be you have to be um willing
to adapt do you think shorting should is
should be legal do you think it's
ethical like to me I'm not I don't know
much about investing but I feel like
it feels wrong now I know
if uh something is over inflated
it's good for there to be an opposing
Force to like balance it or something
like that but it just feels like in our
current modern internet world I think
Tesla I vaguely saw somewhere that's
like the most shorted stock like ever
and so that incentivizes a lot of
um the publication of misinformation
about it like it just feels like the
incentives are wrong not when we look at
the markets but at the future of human
civilization perspective it just feels
like shorting is somehow wrong but maybe
maybe I'm misunderstanding the broader
picture of markets well I actually try
not to do that I like I almost only take
long positions specifically because I
feel like you're at betting betting like
on world collapsing I just I feel like
morally I don't want to be in that that
I don't I don't want to have that
Viewpoint I think you know that sort of
is another thing that I've noticed like
I've been very lucky I've traveled a lot
I've met a lot of a lot of famous people
and the one thing that I know notices
like a lot of a lot of the people who
are the most successful they're the ones
who are very optimistic no matter what
is happening day to day they remain very
optimistic about the future of where
things are going
um so so I try not to enter in that
situation I think as far as like
shorting specifically the real danger to
me is that anybody can now invest and I
feel like actually some of these apps
like Robinhood they go out of their way
to try and make it seem like it's this
fun game
um like I I I've seen people where you
place a trade and like it gives you like
like these stickers or these pop-ups
like of confetti and it's like wait a
second what what's what's going on here
um with the whole with the whole game
like people are sort of they're going
after the wrong thing
um so I I don't think shorting like will
be banned but I think it's very
dangerous that everybody has access to
to being able to do things like that so
according to Reddit on the topic of
Tesla
uh you have trouble admitting when you
make a mistake is that true
um no that's that's generally not true
actually I think that way Reddit is not
100
accurate and truthful in its
representation of a character that's
fascinating no I think I think the thing
that I I've learned is I'm obviously
very good at chess but that doesn't
automatically mean that I'm I'm a genius
and everything else and I feel like
that's another thing actually I really
really admire about Magnus is that he is
the world champion is the best player
but he does not automatically believe
that translate to EV translates to every
area of life I feel like with some other
world champions they think that they're
great no matter what they do
um and that's not not like intentionally
trying to be like be like rude but I do
feel like there's certain people who
feel like that like anything they say is
right and they are the authority
um when in reality like we are the
authorities when it comes to chess like
we know trust the best we are the
experts but that doesn't automatically
mean we're Geniuses and everything else
that said I think you said somewhere it
could have been on on the c squared
podcast that
I forget if it's chess or streaming that
taught you to generalize the various
like you feel like you're able to do
other things now was that streaming I
don't know if that's specifically
streaming but I think streaming has
taught me a lot about sort of life and
also how to run run a business honestly
like I've I have read a lot of business
books and one of the things with
streaming is that when you start out
it's like this very small thing it's
just you maybe of a couple of people who
help you along the way but as it becomes
bigger or bigger if there's a boom you
suddenly start having to hire employees
you're basically running this business
and like for me I've I've learned a lot
about that because one one of there was
this book that I read some years back I
think it was by Mary Buffett it was on
Warren Buffett and and how like he tries
to be hands off like when he buys these
companies it's hands-off management
stays the same you don't do anything and
I actually I try to do things kind of
the same way where like I try to be
hands off there are a couple people
around me I leave a lot of the general
day-to-day decisions up to them and then
like things that are really important
obviously I'm involved in but I try to
do things like that so streaming is you
learn a lot along the way and I think
now having done that there probably are
several other potential careers that I
that I could have if I really wanted to